love to hear the buzz in the room
welcome everyone it's just fabulous to
have this room so full
this community and it can you hear me
now okay welcome everybody my name is
Ann Kurth I'm the Dean of the School of
Nursing and it is an absolute joy to
welcome everyone here to Yale nursing's
16th Creative Writing Awards I really
want to thank everyone for coming out
there is so much work that goes into
this beautiful event and and Linda is
going to be thanking people as well our
sponsors and everyone but really it's
about supporting the students and we
love this school there's numbers we can
throw around I'm very proud to say that
we ranked now in the top 5 of schools of
Nursing United States we're top 10 in
the world and we got the recruited ation
last week with flying colors
[Music]
but you know those are numbers right I
said numbers and numbers num but stories
tell and that's really what this night
is about the amazing stories of students
sharing their experiences in their
journey as nurses we have an amazing
offer here tonight Theresa Brown who has
also done that on the national and
international stage talking about that
journey and so you're going to have a
beautiful evening and those of you who
are not nurses in the audience raise
your hand okay own it
someone graciously said to me while we
were mingling outside she said you know
if you want to know about nurses and
about nursing you come to this event so
I just want to again welcome everyone
we're really proud that you're part of
our community there's no one else in our
community who's more central to this
event and to what we do then Linda Honan
it's my pleasure
[Applause]
right
all right is it you people need to get
out more all right we are honored to
welcome Teresa Brown registered nurse
oncology and hospice clinician New York
Times opinion writer contributor to CNN
na JN and former English professor at
Tufts University her first book critical
care a new nurse faces death life and
everything in between
is required reading for nursing students
and programs around the country her
second book is titled one nurse twelve
hours for patients lives the shift is
also a New York Times bestseller
she has been published in JAMA and the
Pittsburgh post-gazette has been a guest
on MSNBC live and NPR's fresh air it may
have taken us 16 years to find the
absolutely perfect person to speak with
us tonight a nurse who writes nursing
her books and her stories eloquently
speak to the complexity that she
experiences doing clinical work when I
was a doctoral student taking my first
class on qualitative research I learned
of something called the phenomenological
nod that's the instinctive reaction that
one has when one reads truth from the
simple experience of searching for the
ever elusive pillows in the hospital to
the complexity of not just a desire to
care for people but the dedication to
caring about people to the grit and the
cojones that are needed to do our work
of the difficulty in perfecting
technical skills the messy often dirty
swampy low life of clinical practice the
ubiquitous nature of alarms and
and the gross inefficiency of hospitals
the power plays between doctors and
nurses nurses and nurse managers often
disguised as rules but really maybe
about being a bully from no lunches to
epic charting the impact of patient
ratios on an actual human level time as
the enemy of the good
I promise you if you are a clinician
your head will be nodding all the way
through the shift
she speaks truth about nursing being the
canary in the coal mine Theresa observes
she watches she listens while she nurses
she takes in conversations the
environment the context and then she
narrates nurses lives as we struggle
with system and competence as well as
our own social constraint and breaking
power structures ambition and apathy she
tells our story she validates our lives
the more than that she gives us insight
she makes us braver than we think we are
ladies and gentlemen I am honored to
introduce you to jury surround a nurse
who writes nursing
what an incredibly lovely lovely
introduction really thank you so much
and it's really a pleasure to be here I
keep hearing and this is an amazing
event and I feel like wow I get to come
to it and be part of it so that's very
exciting
I'm gonna start with my background
someone was when we were taking pictures
someone mentioned that my bio says in a
past life I got a PhD in English and
from the sari I hope you're not thirsty
yeah you can have mine I only drink a
little bit you know so someone was
saying in my bio says in my past life I
got a PhD in English from the University
of Chicago and then taught at Tufts for
three years and their writing program
and the question I always get asked and
it's in fact at the start of my first
book critical care is you left teaching
English for this usually said in a
hospital setting or in the minute we're
in the middle of some sort of horrible
thing that's happening and people just
can't imagine why anyone would leave a
calm collected classroom to come to the
chaos of health care and the chaos of
sick people right and trying to make
them better
so I called this the million dollar
question because the implication is
always that I would have to give them a
million dollars to make the same choice
but actually I've never had any regrets
at all I think the only thing is that I
had a slow falling away from academia my
dad he's retired now but he was a
philosophy professor down in Springfield
Missouri where I grew up in the heart of
the Ozarks and I just thought he had the
coolest job in the world and first of
all his office building was white marble
and I mean the whole camp this wasn't
like that they must have put so much of
their money into this one building you
know but it was the state school right
sort of you know got bigger in the 70s
but his building was amazing and it was
white marble I'd had these columns and I
just thought this is the home of
knowledge right and then if you're a
professor you go in and you work with
students like all of you you know
interested excited or many of you
interested excited students and you help
them learn things and you guide them
and I just seemed so so so wonderful to
live in the world of ideas and thinking
and so I decided to get a PhD in English
not philosophy started teaching at Tufts
and discovered that lo and behold my
father's dream job was not my dream job
which when you've spent six years
getting a PhD is a little painful to
then say okay now what am I gonna be
when I grow up and one lesson to all of
you especially especially in nursing you
have so many options and there are some
people who they know what they want to
be like my husband he wanted to do
physics he got a PhD in physics he's a
physics professor at University of
Pittsburgh he's the chair of the physics
department at University of Pittsburgh
you know that's been his trajectory
other people are more like me you do one
thing well maybe I'm a little extreme
but you know you do one thing and then
you think wow could I do something else
this is the beauty of Nursing there are
so many different opportunities and it's
so so important to know that I just
really want you to keep that in mind if
whatever you're doing isn't working out
it was probably something else you could
do in nursing that would also be
satisfying but for me you know there's
not that many options with a PhD in
English and basically I discovered the
world of ideas wasn't quite doing it for
me then I got pregnant with twins the
pregnancy was planned not the twin part
and I had midwives who
and when the twin girls they just turned
20 they're sophomores in college but
when they're about 18 months we had a
friend visit who was a nurse and this is
truly one of these moments I will never
forget a true life-changing moment where
we were sitting out in the grass and it
was August and the Sun was coming
through and these two little blonde
heads running around and the Sun and I
was talking to my friend and I said you
know I just thought the midwives had the
coolest job in the world and she looked
at me and she said Theresa you could do
that job and it had never crossed my
mind ever there was no one in my family
in health care in fact my dad loved to
say that all doctors were quacks and I
had never ever thought about it ever
and also I sort of had this burden of
having a PhD in like luck you go from
having a PhD to being a nurse and then I
did some research and it turns out you
can so I discovered accelerated nursing
programs and I was sold literally within
a month I was taking chemistry we were
living in New Jersey at that time so I
was taking chemistry at Rutgers because
now I had to go back to school and take
all the science classes I had never
taken the truth is that I loved them
I loved the concreteness of it in
graduate school everything was about
jargon that I often didn't understand
we're not really sure anyone did but I
really loved the concreteness of the
liver you know
or you do a conversion problem at doe
since you know the number the answer is
three I like that yeah so that's how I
got into nursing then we ended up moving
to Pittsburgh and I did Pitts
accelerated program I'm sure it's you
know not quite as good as Yale's but I
got a great education and then I started
working as a nurse and I really felt
with no regret that this sort of more
intellectual part of my life part of my
professional life was done and that was
okay I'm you know I had no problems with
that I can still read whatever I want I
can think my thoughts right if I get the
urge to read a very dense dark and
filled books that I don't understand I
can do that even while working as a
nurse but then I had a very very bad
experience as a new nurse where a
patient who was supposed to go home
started coughing up blood and
essentially died and she was supposed to
go home in a few hours
and I can finally tell this story and
not feel sick which is sort of a
testament to how long it takes to
process these events and for the nurses
in this room if you haven't had an
experience like this yet you will have
one you will have someone who you
thought was okay who's gonna die and you
will suddenly be confronted with the
fragility of the human body and the
limits of what we're able to do for
people and this will be a make-or-break
moment for you and you're really gonna
have to go and draw on all your training
to get through that moment but you can
get through it but for me at this time
I couldn't move past it and was still
able to go to work and live my life but
it was so stuck in my brain and I
thought okay I'm gonna write this down
sort of like the Pensieve in Harry
Potter were like you pull the memories
out
and I thought I'll feel better if I can
put this on paper and that doesn't work
I mean it really has taken me many years
of telling and retelling this story to
come to terms with it but I really liked
what I wrote and I thought okay aim high
I've always wanted something in the New
York Times I'm gonna send this to the
New York Times so I sent it to the
magazine and at that time I had a friend
on the editorial staff and I I sent it
to him and I said hey can you help me do
you know anyone at the magazine and he
said I don't but this is great and I
hope it's okay I send it to the science
times the Tuesday section on science and
health and they wrote back to me and
said we're gonna take this and I was I
couldn't believe it and then it took six
months for them to publish it I was
truly I was starting to imagine it that
I had gotten this email and I was just
getting ready to email the guy and say
hey did you really say you're gonna
publish this when he emailed me and said
we're finally publishing your piece and
they said on a photographer who took the
it's still it's called perhaps death is
proud you can see it online he took
these incredibly spooky pictures of me
through glass and but it came out and
you know like everyone I was hoping my
mom would read it right and some of my
friends and I was totally unprepared for
the huge positive reaction that this
piece got and I started hearing from
editors and book agents and the thing I
really took home was people said to me
this is a voice we never hear the voice
of a bedside nurse and I took that and I
really kept it as my mantra and my sense
of mission and I suddenly realized I had
this amazing opportunity to as best I
could be a spokesperson for nursing but
to really tell the truth about Nursing
I'm so happy that Linda said that's
exactly what I do
because that was always my aim and the
contract for my first book critical care
actually came from that article so I was
great person right place right time but
also right voice and a sense of here
comes someone who can maybe fill a
vacuum that we weren't even really aware
of because there's so many stories about
doctors right and doctors writing and so
few stories about nurses writing
although I have seen a few more nursing
memoirs now christy watkins language of
kindness just came out and there's
another new book that i shoot i'm always
getting the title wrong something like
how to care but it's more artful than
that and I apologize Molly case is the
author's name I apologize I'm not
getting it right but I realized this was
an opportunity for me to show first of
all what nurses really do right not what
we do on Grey's Anatomy you know which
is nothing basically you know or all
those doctor shows that didn't even get
nursing wrong they just don't get
nursing at all and when I've been in a
position to talk about that I've told
people you know could you just have
nurses on those shows do the things that
nurses actually do and my personal
favorite is when the doctor comes in and
he he lovingly looks at the IV tubing
and
you know I mean I remember one time an
IV pump wouldn't stop beeping and so the
doctor just turned it off like what I
can't do that
so there is a there is a vacuum of true
stories about what we do and that's a
problem because then people don't know
how important nurses are to the quality
of care and if you're not familiar with
the work of Linda akin at UPenn about
staffing and there's other people too
but Linda's really the most well known
person who's done this and enough
luminously is the right word but she's
produced a lot of research relative
relevant to this is that if you look at
nurses being staffed to a certain level
every time that number goes down
patients who wouldn't have died in the
hospital will die you know this is on a
statistical level a big level right
we're not talking about 10 people
although it could be 10 people depending
on what's going on in any particular
floor all of you need to know that I
know a lot of you are pursuing graduate
degrees and you'll be doing graduate
work but you still need to be aware of
how integral nurses are to not just
quality of care but patient survival
right this is really really important
and so that's what I started doing let's
show what nurses really do and so at
that time I was writing a lot for the
well blog for the New York Times and
stories about when a patient dies or how
do you deal with all the grief that we
have in oncology and a lot of columns
that ended up being about relationships
with patients but also each other nurse
to nurse bullying you know a horrible
ugly topic that still needs to be talked
about because it still happens and then
I slowly switched over to writing
opinion columns my first one was about
staffing
and I realized I was reflecting on this
there's that word reflecting right it's
reflecting on this thinking about this
talk and I realized that my mission has
somewhat not changed but let's say
broadened out to include the idea that
nurses are experts and I hadn't thought
about that but it's really true when I
wrote a column about why do all drugs
have two names and and how confusing
that is and since I've been working in
home hospice it's it's very confusing to
patients it's very confusing to patients
it's sort of scarily confusing to
patients actually I wrote another column
about why can't we have a single Med
list for every patient and this came up
because again in hospice people get
discharged the meds they have in their
brown paper bag the meds that are on
their list from the hospital the meds
they got from their three four or five
different doctors offices none of them
agree and the patient isn't even sure
what they're supposed to be taking this
is a problem right
and so preview next weekend I got bumped
for the molar report but I shouldn't
that's true it's true I should have a
show and unless there's another big
political bombshell have a column in The
Times talking about how we make
decisions about whether patients are
appropriate for comfort care or not and
none of those columns are specifically
about what nurses do right but they draw
on my experience as a nurse and I'm a
nurse writing them like that's the thing
right I am a nurse I mean it's funny
when I started writing there were some
people who is like is she real I don't
believe she's a nurse she's not really a
nurse you know this is this sort of
prejudice whole idea that you couldn't
have a nurse who could really write
about health care who could really think
about health care and I just want to say
guess what there's a lot of nurses who
can think of write about health care
and I know that some of them are sitting
in this room tonight
[Applause]
so we as a profession I see are becoming
more visible this is my hopeful
interpretation there's international
nursing movements however you feel about
unions they're in my view doing some
good work trying to highlight the
importance of staffing which is a really
critical issue there's not also
non-union organizations trying to talk
about staffing I feel like it's just
sort of there in in the air the sense
that what nurses do and the importance
of Nursing is being seen more people are
acknowledging it more and I I really
feel the most hopeful about this when I
meet with new interns and residents
which occasionally comes up because I'll
do something at Pitt oh actually I also
gave a medical Grand Rounds and I can
tell you the story about the doctor who
like five times said you're giving the
medical Grand Rounds and I kept saying
yeah I'm giving the medical Grand Rounds
anyway
yeah I guess you thought I should only
be in the nursing Grand Rounds but I'm
anyway I do feel very hopeful when I
meet interns and residents and fellows
who do see nurses as colleagues and
really want to have a good relationship
with the nurses on their floor and you
know are very much like call me by my
first name and and I think they just are
more informal than perhaps the
generation before them but also they
have a better understanding of sort of
the intricacies of all the interlocking
parts of healthcare and I always say
that nurses don't really learn much
about doctors doctors don't really learn
much about nurses then you put these two
groups together and we are supposed to
be together the instrument of how
healthcare happens in the hospital and
home care so for the sickest patients
you have these two groups of people who
don't know anything about each other
suddenly having two very intensely work
together it should not be a surprise
that this leads to problems but what
each of us can do about this and this is
the mission that I'm gonna pass on to
all of you I know that a lot of you
right I know that you're good at it
there's probably some of you who don't
write and hate writing and that's okay
because the real job of nurses who are
leaders and everyone can be a leader
whatever job you're in remember that
also but the real job of nurses who are
leaders it's not just to be great at
your clinical work but I would say as
much as you can do this same mission
that I've embraced for myself what can
you teach the world about what nurses do
what can you teach your family about
what you actually do every day what can
you teach the physicians you work with
about how important your role is and all
these things may sound very very basic
but that's where I started you know
that's what I started with with that
impulse and Linda said oh for sick took
us 16 years to find the right person to
be the speaker here which is not
necessarily true but the point is that
that's a powerful motivation for me and
it can equally be a powerful powerful
motivation for all of you right so I
want to leave you with that charge we
have so many stories by doctors and some
of them are beautiful and some of them
are very helpful and some of them have
pointed out serious problems and the
problem isn't the doctor narrative right
the problem is that we don't have our
voice out there also we don't have a
seat at that storytelling table so I'm
gonna borrow from shirley Chisholm I
just find out this great quotation that
she said if you don't have a seat at the
table
everyone knows who shirley Chisholm was
if you don't you can google her right
though
so she said if they don't give you a
seat at the table bring a folding chair
so I'm going to tell you if you feel
like you know the space for your story
find a space keep writing bring your
laptop get to work and congratulations
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much and thank you to our
distinguished guests for taking the time
out of your busy life to support the
creative writing award writ large the
function of narrative or story is to
connect to the reader the connection is
joined not so much with the intellect of
the reader but to a sense of if not
shared at least appreciated lived
experience that takes the form of
feeling that is why story is often
considered controversial feeling except
in psychiatry is not to be mined in
scholarship or science it needs to be
covered up by method by statistics by
objectivity but story is subjective it
gives us insight into the world of
Nursing and the gifts our students give
the world and tonight is about giving
voice to our students what originated as
an assignment where students were asked
to journal about the process of becoming
a nurse or living the life of a nurse
culminated in this event we learn to
write what and how we think to unearth
lessons to preserve moments to discern
both the complexities of our experiences
and often the systemic factors that are
associated with them
that's why we write but to move them
beyond the personal to the public offers
opportunities to see our profession in
real and accessible ways and tonight we
are celebrating 16 years of Yale nurses
writing nursing
[Applause]
we received 96 submissions for tonight's
award and with a great deal of gifts
difficulty the original submissions were
narrowed to 16 by Nina Adams dr. Deborah
Foss dr. Lawrence Gutterman Don Hubbard
Katie pelic Oh Mary Pearson and she'll
Swanson the final submissions were
whisked away to our four distinguished
judges echo heron critical care nurse in
New York Times bestselling author of
nine books and Fadiman award-winning
author essayist editor and teacher Anna
Quindlen Pulitzer Prize winning author
and leave Woodworth author of three
best-selling books those top writers are
Sebastien best Marianne Blauman
raid Caliendo
Harley Chung Lauren Eddie
Jeff Harris Silvia King
Elizabeth Rinker janessa piano start
Nicky Stockman Naomi Schwartz and Sarah
Van Buren in addition we saluted an
additional twenty students I would like
to acknowledge all of those students
efforts and let you know that you have a
small gift and that is the top
twenty-nine submissions tonight
tonight's contest are compiled in a chat
book for you to take home the three
winners tonight will receive a citation
and a check for $1,000 and of course the
honor of reading before this
distinguished group finally before I
introduce you to the students I want to
acknowledge that tonight would not have
happened without the support and the
generosity of sponsors Leslie Mills of
the Griswold special care we'd like to
thank her for a generosity and created
and endowed fund to support this award
Beth Beckman chief nursing executive for
Yale New Haven Health System and inna
Williams senior vice president and chief
nursing executive for Yale New Haven
Hospital were platinum level sponsors
this year in the distant past
additional sponsors included Judy Krause
former dean and head of silliman college
Kimberly M Gulf cruise office of the
secretary and Vice President of Student
Life and the Charles Gallaudet Trumbull
lectureship Cassie and John Picard John
H Driscoll and the Webster private bank
Wolters Kluwer sner Seng education Linda
Schwartz ed Cleary the Gustafson family
and Dean and Kurth along with thank yous
to Debra Foss Holly Kennedy and Carol
and wet Martha and finally an event like
this equals increase work for countless
people that is often completely
unrelated to their job descriptions from
Neal Greene who photographed our winners
I feel like I should scream Meall right
now to Neve Emerson who edited all
documents in aided in securing
sponsorship to Charlotte parodies who
man the online registration system and
all the tick lists for the past month
tracy chit see also known as my right
hand she edited every document and was a
livery service for flowers and chapbooks
lauren lauren Langford who created our
invitation and tonight's program and our
administrative team of Nancy DiMaggio
Jeanette C Pratt's Christina Kinser ski
and Colleen Cole Byrd who tallied return
phone calls deposited checked looked up
home addresses orchestrated printed
helped budget and managed to make
tonight a success so thank you all
without further ado let me introduce you
to our top three writers our first
reader will be Diana Kim
diana is a women's health and midwifery
student yes yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
anybody else I'll take your money next
year yeah Diane is a women's health and
midwifery student her favorite parts of
Yale include the Yale University art
gallery the Wyndham Campbell festival
and their inspiring Yale School of
Nursing classmates after graduating from
UC Davis in 2013 with a BA in
international relationships and Italian
she worked in public health and she
joined the Peace Corps her time working
in Cameroon showed that she wanted to
spend her life working with women since
moving to New Haven she has volunteered
with the Haven free clinic Planned
Parenthood and the Yale patient
navigation program and she plans to
pursue a career in global health Diane
oh my god all right hello um so my name
is Diane and this piece is pretty much
dedicated to all the students and
teachers of anatomy and I wrote it about
my time training to be a TA for this
year's class I have seen the human body
do incredible things and as a minimum
free student it is no surprise to others
that I would say the greatest thing I
witnessed is the body's ability to bring
new life into the world but just as
remarkable than this is the body and
death and I know this as a student of
anatomy who has had the privilege of
examining and marveling at the
intricacies of the human body inside and
out so how do I love the anatomy let me
count the ways
lifting the bowels out of the abdominal
cavity and never quite being able to
have them lie exactly as they were
snipping away at the great cardiac
vessels in order to liberate the heart
and create a look between our hands
tracing the indentation of the aorta
along the surface of the left lung an
eye a window to the soul the size of a
cherry between my fingers the surprising
toughness of a sclera and the oozing of
the aqueous humor and just when you
thought you could name all of the
structures in view there are hundreds
more waiting for you to say their names
and to give them life I have to say
nothing quite triggers an existential
crisis like spending time amongst the
dead in anatomy lab before us were
bodies who had lived and loved and were
still dear to those they had left behind
still displaying a hint of life their
faces are covered with linen shrouds
that I don't have the courage to remove
until a few days later when they are
more an array of organs than bodies I
walk out of the first day of lab into
the afternoon Sun confronted with the
realization that I could devote myself
to Anatomy for the rest of my life and I
would still never unlock all the secrets
of the human body and all of a sudden I
can't help but feel tiny and small
but by the third day my philosophical
quandary is resolved and it's business
as usual my musings are more about
things like whether I'm going to be a
vegetarian after this experience and I
know that I won't buy the last day this
body and I are the best of friends I
know her I know right when I talked away
her foot so that I could reveal her
dorsalis pedis the next morning we use a
bone saw to remove a leg in order to get
a midsagittal via with a pelvis as my
classmates continue with their work I
quietly settle into mine
discovering the vasculature of this
lower extremity that has been removed
from its owner layer by layer I moved
through skin fat and muscle and
eventually uncover the beginnings of the
popliteal artery and it's pearly and
springy beauty my gloves are greasy from
working with adipose tissue I am careful
as I trace the winding path of the
vasculature down her calf lest I Nick a
vessel and spoil blood on to this
beautiful view the work is so calming so
therapeutic that my usual inner
monologue now just sounds like elevator
music I find joy in the slow and
methodical work and think to myself that
this must be why people find joy in
things like cross stitching but I think
that this is much better I am brought
back to the surface by the sound of the
electrical saw and the smell of bone
dust I step up on a stool to get a
better look at what is happening at the
other at the other end of the table and
I see that my classmates have progressed
to removing the top of her skull as I
lean over her body I realized I am
cradling her hand in mine in an odd
gesture of intimacy I squeeze it harder
and I hope that she finds comfort and
knowing that there are students
patiently vying for their chance to hold
the saw to lift the cranial cap to
discover the contents of her skull like
opening a box on Christmas Day surely
she knew that this would happen
just like the donor with the words go
Harvard tattooed where the Sun doesn't
shine
he definitely knew this really happened
he definitely knew and I hope it brought
him as much joy as it did to us when we
saw it this body will be turned into
ashes once we have learned what we could
but the experience will stay with me
forever we may all just be beings
fighting for Revlon's in a place in this
world and our knowledge may disappear
with us but each day I will strive to
know just a little bit more than I did
the day before thank you
[Applause]
our second reader will be kamila soda
Espinoza Camila is an international
first chair keppen student her chosen
specialty is midwifery women's health
with a concentration in global health
she graduated from the University of
concepción chile in 2015 as a midwife
and a child care specialist and worked
for two years in public hospitals caring
for the vulnerable at-risk communities
in chile her experience working with
immigrant patients in Chile strengthened
her long-term commitment to become a
midwife of the world and provide
inclusive patient-centered care to
Hispanic communities in english-speaking
countries and underserved communities
around the globe
[Applause]
my biggest achievement of the night is
climbing up that stair without falling
yes my name is Camilla I want you all to
know that I'm doing this in my second
language that's why I'm really nervous
hopefully in my blood I carry the legacy
of the heroes that shaped me the
nurturing woman from whom I inherited
the golden heart that future nurses are
born with yet I don't come from a family
of nurses the their calling unlike mine
went unanswered the circumstances of
their birth and upbringing unsure they
would be denied the chance and the
opportunities born in poverty and race
immense violence they were hobbled with
virtual change with virtual chains
affixed to their ankles unable to move
freely beyond the blocks of a small poor
neighborhood in a city in the north of
Chile but they refuse to let hostility
touch us the men that forcefully turned
them into women before they reach
puberty did not get to lay a hand on us
all their nurturing and healing
potentials plays solemnly on trying to
ensure we would become what they
couldn't a meal that ought to serve for
magical effect ends so no child would go
to bed hungry even if it meant they
themselves would have to the single pair
of school shoes they could afford was
shared and passed down so no child would
be denied the education they were
deprived off in the midst of the spear
they gathered together and created the
village it took two races all we did
have it better frequent and loud
laughter is a part of all our childhood
memories but the omnipotent present of
macho culture was out there waiting to
break us was we left the nest they so
lovingly created we the girls that
became women were also abused too soon
red and purple marks blossom in our
skins and the echo of recent screams
became the soundtrack of at least one
chapter in our lives but we didn't let
that define us and the core of nurturing
professions went on as generation after
generation had at least one woman who
tried but for some reason or another
succumbed to the circumstances that
scarred their bodies and broke their
resolve yet each one pushed a little
further than one before her and it was
their footsteps that I started to follow
one sick hauling made me thrust forward
with the urgency of destiny
the beginning was easy they had cleared
the path as they ventured onto it it
wasn't until I made it further than any
other women in my bloodline of the
challenge really begun but there they
were to uplift me and encouraged me
during the journey their breaths caught
with the collective longing for a letter
of acceptance their tears of joy run as
freely as mine when it finally arrived
their anguish to join my own when the
cost of the Challenger now to me more
than I could ever afford and they used
every resource at their disposal to make
sure that money wouldn't keep me from
trying it was because of them that I
became the first women in my family to
hold a college degree and the first to
leave the nest and become an immigrant
with a mission to serve the seekers and
the dreamers that had arrived at this
foreign lands just like me my successors
were the product of a team's
effort and even after giving me
everything they still had one more gift
before my departure in the middle of our
last family reunion
sat me down and in my hands please years
of collective wisdom of stories of
personal Wars and times of peace until
my commitment was sealed with fire and I
was thoroughly reminded of who I would
serve women like them women like me
women like us your duty is to help they
taught me to nurture to care to bring
health when health can be restored and
to tend to strangers when health has
been lost and death is near and waiting
sometimes patiently sometimes not so
much your duty is to protect from
judgment from harm especially your own
take off your beliefs and your morals
before you put on your white coat you
will fail your pages if you ever let
that taint a medical assessment look at
your patients greet them with kindness
even when they are anything but kind
pain has given them no rest and by the
time they come to you they are already
exhausted from suffering you will never
be able to understand what it truly
means to walk a day in their shoes but
you should always try Society has stolen
the voice of many and it will be your
privilege and your responsibility to
advocate for them until they get it back
no person chooses poverty when they have
any other choice when resources are
scarce it's hard to see the urgency of a
future beyond tomorrow you'll want to
scream in frustration as your
recommendations fall onto what seems to
be deaf ears and indifferent hearts but
forgive them forgive us we have made the
same mistakes and have been labeled
non-compliant with treatment but
prevention is hard when putting food on
the table is the daily struggle that
overshadows all your waking hours
treatment is even harder when you have
to choose between the medication that
could save your life and the school
supplies your child needs to keep
chasing a better tomorrow
be grateful hundreds of strangers who
place their trust in you open their
hearts and confess
they have not even there to admit to
their gods protect their trust and
they'll show you their scars ask the
right questions and their sorrows will
come pouring out but use anything they
share as a weapon to elicit guilt and
false compliance and you'll lose a
bridge to their souls forever honor your
degree you are one of the lucky few who
has been given the gift of knowledge and
the language to understand it be humble
use it wisely share it freely understand
that your mistakes weigh more heavily
than those committed by anyone who chose
a different path that is the burning up
holding life in your hands but as
never-ending mystery that humanity
reveals as it unfolds you come to
understand that mistakes are inevitable
tragedies of our flawed and beautiful
existence and you have to learn to ask
for forgiveness and forgive yourself in
the rare occasions that you make them
eat sleep and stay in touch you have
been called in to nursing and this is as
much a curse as it is a blessing you
will forsake your own well-being for the
sake of becoming the nurse you are
aspire to be you will lose birthdays
funeral dates and in the process loved
ones who are unable to understand why
you choose to care for in console
strangers in the most important moments
of their lives at the expense of doing
the same for your own people that is the
inevitable price to pay
trying to squeeze whatever living you
can do in the breaks between one shift
and the next and accepting the locks of
those who are unable to understand it it
will be hard impossible at times they
concluded but rest assure my dear the
sacrifice is worth it because it's
golden heart we gave you wouldn't beat
us hard and as passionately if you were
doing anything else I am here today
representing more people than just
myself with my life I have promised to
build them
after every grueling shift and every
sleepless night of studying I have laid
as offerings at their feet because I
would be nothing without my heroes the
best nurses the world never got to know
the women of my family thank you
[Applause]
our final reader will be Cael Wardell
jail graduated Phi Beta Kappa in
psychology neuroscience from Colby
College in 2013 at Colby she played
varsity field hockey
she's which is hard to believe when you
see the size of her you don't know her
she studied art in literature at Saint
Petersburg Russia she served as the
president of the student health on
campus and after graduation ko worked in
psychologist psychiatric research at
Northwestern and at Boston University's
where she discovered she would rather
work directly with patients instead of
analyzing data from behind a computer
screen in a cubicle in Chicago she left
her best friend Henry but is eternally
grateful for his unwavering support kale
is in her first specialty here and will
graduate as a psychiatric mental health
nurse practitioner
I made sure I wore heels so I could see
above the podium so my piece is called a
small white card what does it mean to be
a nurse I did not know hidden money in
my wallet there was a small white card
issued from the state of Connecticut
with six numbers on it those six numbers
held the power to declare me a licensed
registered nurse I thought if I stare it
at the words on this card long enough
maybe I would feel like the person it
declared me to be yet I knew that I keep
kept this tattered piece of paper with
me at all times as a subconscious and
perilous attempt to quell an inner voice
that told me I was not a real nurse by
December 3rd I had fully accepted that
it would probably never feel like a real
nurse and that now faded card still
carefully guarded in my wallet felt more
like a mere formality on the path to
graduation that cool December morning
had begun with an ungodly early alarm a
train ride to Chicago
O'Hare's International Airport and a
disappointing middle seat assignment as
I sat squished between two strangers I
began to read my neuroscience textbook
the chapter for the next day's class was
on sleep something I desperately needed
and it felt like the book was almost
mocking me as I read about sleep stages
and neurotransmitters my head fell
rhythmically and I nodded off I was
abruptly awoken by announcement an
announcement over the planes intercom
system a panicked voice asked if any
life since health care professionals
were on board the plane I felt a rush of
fear fill my entire body as I
into the words surely there would be a
doctor or a real nurse on board second
strike by and suddenly times seem to
stand still no one had come forth a
second announcement was made if there
are any licensed health care
professionals on board please press the
call button I knew I had a choice I
could cowardly hide in my middle seat
and no one would know about that
tattered white card in my wallet or I
could put aside my self-doubt and rise
to a much greater calling in that moment
I did not know if what I had to offer
was enough but did know that it came to
Yale in order to fill a fulfill a
lifelong desire to help others and that
was why I pushed the button the call but
as the call button lit up above my seat
dozens of curious apprehensive eyes made
contact with minds a final announcement
was made could the health care
professional please report to the front
of the plan I stood up and made my way
down the aisle from the second-to-last
row heads turned and my face grew warm
as I felt hundreds of glares sizing up
my 5-foot frame walking to the front of
the aircraft my mind raced with
scenarios with which I might face when I
reached the end of the seemingly endless
aisle I rehearsed the acronym Mona
[Laughter]
as I desperately tried to recall other
medical surgical knowledge that I had
ground into my head that past year as
the front of the plane near I heard
cries of pain coming from a flight
attendant sprawled across the jump seat
holding a blood-soaked napkin over her
left eye the same panic voice I had
heard over the loudspeaker explained to
me that as we were preparing for takeoff
Brianna had opened an overhead bin and a
free-floating laptop had hit her
directly in the eye his voice began to
quiver as he explained that Brianna had
corneal implants and the impact plant
must have dislodged the impact must have
dislodged the implant I think he sensed
the confusion on my face because he
handed me medical gloves and said just
go look at it and please tell us what we
should do I turned my attention to prion
ax as I introduce myself my name is Cal
weirdo and I am a nurse even the words
felt foreign and uncomfortable as I
added them however the eerily silent
plane and Brianna's pained whimpers left
no space for self-doubt or hesitation I
began to feel a strange rush of energy
and an instinct I did not even know
existed begin to take over with a sense
of authority words came out of my mouth
call 9-1-1 and taxi back to the gate
immediately I peeled back the napkin she
clutched over her eye as thoughts of
incompetence were replaced by adrenaline
fueled deliberation and focus with each
panicked exhalation her ruptured implant
used further out of her eyeball I heard
a fake cough behind me that morphed in
the sound of uncontrolled retching as I
peered to my right I saw a first-class
passenger vomit into a white paper bag
I turned my focus back on Brianna the
cut over her orbital bone was pouring
blood before I was even cognizant of my
plan I said Brianna we're gonna get
through this I will be here for you the
whole time I just need you to keep your
head as still as possible and take deep
breaths I reached for the gauze pads
from the first-aid kit that had been
placed at my feet and took hold of
Brianna's face with both hands
I needed to stabilize her head with each
small movement the implant became more
dislodged with the other hand I began
applying pressure on the wound to the
left of her eye the gauze pads changed
from a white to a bright red in seconds
medical knowledge rattled in my head as
I tried to sift through facts and bring
them to the front of my mind I took my
left hand off of her head and checked
her pulse 120 okay good
I thought who sacs flooded my mind the
head is extremely vascular and bleeds
more than abrasions the other parts of
the body began to regain a sense of
mental clarity as I trusted an
unfamiliar intuition with slightly more
assurance in my voice I explained to her
that I wanted to check the vision in her
other eye I gently peeled apart her
right eyelid everything looked intact
can you see me I asked I could feel her
not had not an affirmative gesture what
do you think is gonna happen to me am I
gonna lose my eye Brianna asked
desperately the compression had
stabilized the bleeding from the eye
abrasion yet I knew my most important
training was now being called upon
anyone can compress a wound or check a
pulse but Brianna needed more than pure
procedural knowledge she needed me to
hold her pain with her to comfort and
assure her on a deeper level than any
words could convey as I clutched her
head with one hand and held her hand
with the other I felt a grip it was a
grip of fear a grip of trust a grip
between two strangers who needed each
other
the paramedics entered the plane the
tension began to ease in my body as I
calmly explained what happened and my
belief that Breanna needed emergency eye
surgery as Breanna was carted off the
plane I gave her hand a final squeeze of
reassurance before I let go I returned
to my seat and looked down to find
Briana's blood still clinging to my
shirt I sat through the rest of the
flight in a shaky stunned silence off
the flight a slew of phone calls with
power parents and Confused friends
didn't help they didn't quite get it but
I'm not sure I did at that point either
three weeks later I peeled the plastic
film of my freshly dry-cleaned white
shirt pure white that was the last of
the reminders at this point not much
remained the vivid flashbacks had ceased
the bloodstains were washed away and
through a heartwarming inbox message I
had learned to surgeries later even
Brianna had recovered I we folded this
shirt and placed it into the drawer and
flopped onto my duvet I scrolled through
Netflix the new episode of my favorite
mindless reality TV show had not been
released
probably a sign I should go to bed I
closed my eyes and before I could
contemplate anything of substance my
body was overcome with sleep I was back
to that cold December morning on the
tarmac of O'Hare Airport my call button
was illuminated as I heard the
announcement for the healthcare
professional to present to the front of
the plane yet I could not move my body
was paralyzed and sheer panic I fumbled
around for the frayed familiar edges of
that card I prized so dearly I pulled it
out and set it on my tray table the worn
edges were replaced by crisp pointed
corners and it's soiled gray color now
gleamed a pure and assertive white as I
read the card I noticed that the date of
issue was now different it read K award
L R on December 3rd 2018 I put the card
back in my wallet with a sense of pride
I felt the control washed back into my
limbs as I stood up and confidently
walked down
this time I knew what it meant to be a
nurse
[Applause]
I used to say that nurses or secret
keepers we kept our experiences of the
most intense intimate moment in people's
lives cloaked to all but other nurses
but tonight you are privileged to hear
three remarkable nurse writers disclose
their story they are our future and they
are taught at Yale that there is an
expectation that they will be leaders
Mavericks that will make a difference we
need to challenge ourselves to continue
writing about our work tonight you heard
how the anatomy lab is where our
students meet their first patients and
fall in love with the complexity the
challenge and the charity of our donors
that none of us have progressed to where
we are alone whatever we have built is
on the ground that was leveled by those
who came before us some many generations
long ago for others they are the first
and finally the bravery the grit to
enter another's world and simply try to
help knowing that a license will never
prepare you for all the challenges that
are to come the dedication to caring
about people fuels their boldness these
students are the future of our
profession and they will continue to
write about our work as a reminder to
all of us here tonight that we are
incredibly lucky to have these
remarkable people in our profession so
we look forward to seeing you next year
as we eagerly anticipate our students
ability to enchant to inform and to
exclaim that Nursing indeed does matter
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]